hey schön dass ihr dabei seid ZDF heute
live
sie wird in Bomben und Raketen
verschossen Streu Munition das sind
viele kleine Sprengkörper die sich
großflächig verteilen möglichst viele
und vieles Treffen sollen oft explodiert
sie auch nicht und bleibt dann als
Blindgänger liegen eine Gefahr für
Zivilisten insbesondere auch dann wenn
der Krieg eigentlich schon vorbei ist
weltweit wird Streu Munition von über
100 Staaten geächtet dazu zählen nicht
die USA Ukraine und Russland das wird
nämlich auch heute dann interessant und
ein Thema denn die USA planen nun
Streumunition im großen Stil an die
Ukraine zu liefern für den Kampf gegen
die russischen Truppen daher heute bei
uns die Frage geächtete Kriegswaffen für
die Ukraine darüber wollen wir sprechen
was das bedeutet und gemeinsam mit euch
Fragen stellen und eine Analyse abgeben
ihr könnt live mit kommentieren Fragen
stellen im Stream oder per Mail und
zuerst an unseren Korrespondenten in den
USA und Washington emma teven ist jetzt
bei uns hallo
hallo Alisa Emma zu Beginn des Krieges
hatte die US-Regierung noch gesagt wenn
es stimmen sollte dass Streumunition im
russischen Angriffskrieg eingesetzt
würde dann wäre das ein Kriegsverbrechen
das sagte die Sprecherin damals
mittlerweile ist klar dass Russland
Streumunition im großen Stil benutzt hat
auch die Ukraine sie verwendet hat wie
können die USA am Anfang des Krieges den
Einsatz von Streumunition so hart so
scharf verurteilen und sie nun im großen
Stil an die Ukraine liefern wollen
ja es klingt natürlich erstmal nach
Doppelmoral aber hier macht man jetzt
eine Unterscheidung auf einmal in
Washington dass man sagt Russland nutzt
ja diese Munition auf fremdem
Territorium also gegen die Ukraine in
einem Angriffskrieg während
Streumunition zur Verteidigung ja auf
ukrainischem Territorium von
ukrainischen Streitkräften eingesetzt
wurde man sich über die Risiken dort
sehr wohl bewusst ist und man und das
ist das entscheidende Argument diese
Munition schlicht und ergreifend braucht
aus zwei Gründen erstens die
eingegrabenen frontpositionen der
russischen Streitkräfte lassen sich so
ist jedenfalls die Einschätzung der
Militärs nur mit Hilfe solcher Träume
Munition tatsächlich überwinden und der
zweite Punkt ist die herkömmliche
Munition wird langsam knapp man kommt
nicht nach bei der Lieferung aber auch
nicht bei der Produktion von ganz
normalen Granaten und Bomben die man an
die Ukraine ja geliefert hat hat und
deswegen muss man so sagt man das hier
in Washington jetzt auf diese Cluster
Baums also streumun ition zurückgreifen
wollen wir unseren Reporter in der
Ukraine dazu er steht nach rakiv daran
hallo Sarah die Frage jetzt natürlich
wie wird diese Ankündigung der USA in
der Ukraine aufgenommen wollte man da
jetzt andere Waffen oder denkt man
natürlich je mehr Waffen desto besser
wie kommt das an
ja man wollte von Anfang an ganz andere
Waffen und davon auch mehr und wollte
Kampfjets und beim Verbund angreifen zu
können man wollte sehr viel mehr
Kampfpanzer vor allem moderne
Kampfpanzer wieder Leopard 2 als
geliefert wurde vor der Großoffensive
sprach der Oberbefehlshaber saluschni
von 300 Leoparden das wäre eine Anzahl
mit der man die Großoffensive gut führen
können es fehlen auch noch Minenräumen
Panzer und vor allem diese wurden durch
die Luft Überlegenheit und fehlenden
Luftabwehr also Luft Überlegenheit der
auf der russischen Seite und fehlender
Luftabwehr auf ukrainischer Seite
oft getroffen und kam nicht voran ja
also man wünscht sich mehr und die
Streumunition ist das sich der
ukrainischen Militärs und auch Politiker
absolut geeignet gerade an der Südfront
wo man Richtung schon mehr verstoßen
will die Unterlegenheit in der
Artillerie schnell auszugleichen dann
die Streumunition kann bedeuten
schneller geliefert werden als z.B F16
Kampf Flieger und Emma warum haben sich
jetzt die USA für diese Art entschieden
ihm die Streumunition zu liefern für
diese Art der Waffenlieferung
ja weil man schlicht und ergreifend
nicht mehr genug von der herkömmlichen
Artilleriemunition hat tatsächlich hat
die Ukraine in den letzten Wochen so
viel an der Front verschossen das ist
langsam knapp wird hier in den USA
laufen die Fabriken auf Hochtouren wir
haben selber vor kurzem in einer gedreht
in Pennsylvania da werden pro Monat
11.000 neue Granaten hergestellt aber es
reicht eben nicht aus ist nicht schnell
genug um an die Ukraine geliefert zu
werden und deswegen haben die USA den
Schluss gefasst dass sie ja 4,7
Millionen von dieser Streumunition also
Stück Streumunition hier auf Lager haben
das sind Bomben das sind Granaten das
sind auch Raketen und in diesen
enthalten sind eben in der Regel etwa 72
minibomben so könnte man das bezeichnen
und die könnte man da sie vorhanden sind
schnell liefern man verpflichtet sich
die zu liefern die angeblich wenige
Blindgänger produzieren das heißt also
kleine Mini Bomben die dann am Ende
nicht explodieren und eine Gefahr für
die Zivilbevölkerung später darstellen
da gutes angeblich eine Rate von nur
zwei Prozent oder etwas mehr als zwei
Prozent von Blindgängern geben bei der
etwas moderneren Variante dieser
Munition und ganz offenbar hat man das
schon vorbereitet 10.000 Stück dieser
Munition liegen bereits in Europa parat
könnten jederzeit weitergereicht werden
an die Ukraine und man hat offenbar auch
mit den Verbündeten einer grundsatzlinie
besprochen die genau dieselbe ist wie
bei Kampfpanzern und Kampfjets nämlich
dass jede Regierung alleine entscheidet
was sie liefert man ist aber im Konsens
das eben die Ukraine dringend Munition
braucht um überhaupt eine Chance zu
haben am Ende in dieser
auseinandersetzen zu bestehen ein
Kommentar gerade bei uns im Stream bei
Youtube von User Userin fire Igel die
Ukraine hat keine Ahnung was für eine
Büchse sie damit geöffnet hat dabei ist
denn die aktuelle Lage an der Front so
verzweifelt dass man eben jetzt so eine
derartige Waffe im großen Stile zum
Einsatz kommen lässt
also Verzweiflung würde ich das nicht
nennen fakt ist dass gerade an der
südlichen Front jeder Quadratmeter der
zurückerobert wird mit einem hohen
Verlust an Soldatenleben verbunden ist
und um auf den User einzugehen die
Erfahrungen mit Streumunition haben die
Ukraine gemacht nämlich sie wurden von
der russischen Seite eingesetzt auch zum
Beispiel in städtischen Gebieten bei
nikolajev letzten Jahres also ich würde
sagen Verzweiflung ist nicht gegeben
aber es ist eine sehr effiziente Waffe
um diese vier Verteidigungslinien die es
im die russ die russische Armee im Süden
angelegt hat zu durchbrechen und das ist
eine große das große Ziel dieser
gestarteten offensiver und da sind sie
auch bereit diese Waffe einzusetzen
da sie ihn sehr nützt militärisch man
muss auch noch dazu sagen wenn ich das
anmerken darf dass dieser gesamte
Bereich extrem vermiet ist die
Blindgänger haben deshalb auch im nach
dem Krieg nicht so die große Bedeutung
wie zum Beispiel in einem Gebiet was
noch nicht von Kampfhandlungen betroffen
ist denn diese ganze gegen muss und das
wird wahrscheinlich Jahre dauern ganz
systematisch entmint werden wenn der
kriegt mal enden sollte ein wichtiger
Punkt immer zum Schluss an Dich noch die
Frage in vielen Ländern wird die Nutzung
von Streumunition geächtet in den USA
nicht warum nicht
ja die USA haben eben auch erkannt dass
bei speziellen Situationen in dieser Art
von Munition am Ende die wirksamste ist
das klingt natürlich schrecklich und
unendlich makaber und zynisch aber am
Ende ist es eben so dass viele Nationen
rund um den Erdball auch von den USA
erwachten dass sie in bestimmten
Situationen helfen und den
Kriegssituationen beispielsweise in
Syrien das ist das Paradebeispiel aus
den letzten Jahren bereit ist eben
Menschenleben zu riskieren und auch
Waffen und Munition zu investieren so
ist es jetzt auch bei der Ukraine
deswegen wird hier klar darauf
hingewiesen dass die europäischen
Staaten offenbar selber nicht genug
Munition haben um die Ukraine adäquat zu
beliefern das die europäischen Staaten
ganz offenbar auch nicht in den letzten
Jahren dafür gesorgt haben für solche
Fälle entsprechende Munitionsvorräte
anzulegen wir kennen ja die Situation in
Deutschland dass Deutschland zwar
bestimmte Waffensysteme liefern kann
aber es an der notwendigen Munition
fehlt weil sie in der Schweiz oder in
Brasilien hergestellt und von dort
verweiger dafür also mussten die USA
einspringen mit Munition und die wird
schlicht und ergreifend knapp und
deswegen nochmal sagt man hier eben es
gibt gar keine andere Möglichkeit wenn
man nicht im Grunde genommen der den
russischen Streitkräften in den nächsten
Wochen das Feld und den Sieg überlassen
will deswegen muss man diese Munition
liefern und es sind eben in der Tat auch
einige NATO Bündnispartner auch das ist
noch mal glaube ich ein wichtiger
Hinweis Die ebenfalls diese Art von
Munition nicht geächtet haben insgesamt
acht der 31 Bündnispartner der NATO
haben sich dieser Ächtung der
Streumunition nicht angeschlossen anders
als z.B Deutschland Frankreich und
Großbritannien die sich dieser
Konvention angeschlossen haben die
liefern ja auch nicht hat die
Bundesregierung auch bekannt gegeben
aber andere könnten jetzt nach dem
Vorbild der USA ebenfalls solche Streu
Munition an die Ukraine liefern das
stimmt nicht alle haben das geächte die
kritischen Kommentare auch bei uns im
Stream die bleiben die User Userin Sana
kann schreibt ehrlich gesagt welches am
erschreckendsten dass diese Art der
Munition hier nun gerechtfertigt wird
daran sprechen wir zum Schluss mit dir
auch noch darüber wir haben es gerade
gehört also ein paar Länder auch der
NATO haben die Streumunition nicht
geächtet aber international sind es doch
sehr sehr viele die das getan haben
spielt das für die Ukraine jetzt keine
Rolle was das vielleicht auch mit ihrem
Ansehen ist vielleicht das falsche Wort
aber mit dem Bild machen könnte
gegenüber westlichen Unterstützern
UnterstützerInnen die das eben geächtet
haben also hat die Ukraine Sorge jetzt
davor
Sorge haben sie hier nicht
präsidentenberater podoljak hat sich
ganz klar und deutlich geäußert er war
nahezu empört darüber dass Leute
vorgeschlagen haben und diese
Streumunition den möglichen Einsatz und
die Lieferung an die Ukraine kritisiert
haben die Ukraine steht auf seiner Sicht
haben immer noch mit dem Rücken an der
Wand sie haben zwar Erfolge erzielt aber
noch riesige Territorien sind russisch
besetzt die Menschen dort können nicht
in Freiheit leben und es sei auch die
Aufgabe seiner also der Regierung die er
bereit die diese zu befreien und wenn
dafür diese Munition notwendig wäre dann
wäre es aus seiner Moral nahezu eine
unterlassene Hilfe Leistung aus seiner
Sicht umgekehrt ähm das Ansehen ist den
Ukrainern schon sehr wichtig es war in
über ganz bedeutsam zu zeigen dass sie
eine andere Kultur haben dass sie nicht
Russland sind und das ähm ist auch nach
wie vor so aber wenn Sie
salopp vor die Wahl gestellt werden ein
sehr sehr hohes Ansehen im Westen zu
genießen und dafür Helme zu bekommen
oder ein schlechtes ansehen und dafür
wirksame Munition dann entscheiden sich
wahrscheinlich schon sehr sehr viele
Ukraine für die für das schlechtere
ansehen und die größeren Mengen an
wirksamer Munition und ich glaube da
sind ihnen die Leben in ihrer Soldaten
deutlich näher als das Ansehen
Einschätzungen Analysen von Dara Hassan
der Ukraine nach hakiv und Matthi Wissen
live in Washington vielen Dank
wir machen hier gleich weiter mit euren
Fragen wir haben uns dazu auch noch ein
Experten eingeladen aber wir wollen
erstmal schauen auf die Streumunition
die Folgen hat eben auch dann wenn der
Krieg vorbei ist folgen die jetzt
erstmal Jonas Katze uns zusammengefasst
hat
Bilder die zeigen wie Streu Munition
wirkt die Bomben zerfallen in viele
kleine Sprengsätze und richten
verheerende Schäden an sie werden
entweder aus der Luft oder vom Boden
abgefeuert feindliche Streitkräfte
werden so großflächig angegriffen doch
nicht alle minibomben zünden und werden
deshalb so Gefahr auch für Zivilisten
oft für Kinder die Streu Bomben mit
Spielzeug verwechseln können die Folgen
Verstümmelungen und Verbrennungen denn
die Blindgänger lauern im Boden und
können bei Erschütterungen explodieren
auch Jahre später die Entschärfung
gleicht einem Krieg nach dem Krieg auch
deshalb sind streubben international
geächtet das Osloer Übereinkommen über
das Verbot von Streumunition trat am
ersten August 2010 in Kraft mittlerweile
haben es mehr als 100 Staaten
ratifiziert oder unterzeichnet dazu
zählen aber weder Russland noch die
Ukraine auch die USA haben nicht
unterschrieben
und wir haben jetzt bei uns für die
vertiefende Analyse Markus Keim von der
Stiftung Wissenschaft und Politik hallo
schönen guten Tag Herr Heim
es gibt schon viele Fragen bei uns im
Stream und mit einer möchte ich auch
direkt einsteigen das ist jetzt
natürlich auch was viele interessiert
und zwar von Daniel Herbert kommt die
Frage bei Facebook hätte denn diese
Lieferung von Streumunition einen großen
Einfluss auf den Kriegsverlauf was
glauben sie
das ist mir einzuschätzen wollen dann
kommt es auf die Menge an die geliefert
wird
es gibt zwei Hauptzwecke für diese für
den Einsatz dieser streumonation das ist
einmal das was angesprochen und ist
eingegrabene Truppenteile die sich sehr
stark befestigt haben die zu sagen dann
eliminiert werden soll aber viel viel
wichtiger sind noch sogenannte weiche
die wir hinter der Form also die
Infrastruktur des angreifen was ich
denke an Munitionsdepot ich denke an
Flughäfen ich denke an verkehrsnoten
anderes mehr man muss ja sagen mit einer
mit einer Granate kann man etwa so sehen
die üblichen plätzungen die Fläche von
vier Fußballfeldern
von
regnet das sagen darf mit diesen einzeln
und damit den Gegner wirkungsvoll
bekämpfen das heißt man kann mit einem
Einsatz die gesamte Infrastruktur
ur das ging das signifikant schlecht und
darum geht
User Edward Kuhn fragt dann noch ein
bisschen differenzierter auch bei
Youtube nach und fragt sich überwiegen
die kurzfristigen Vorteile die
längerfristigen Nachteile sprich
effektivere Bekämpfung von Minen
Infanterie versus vermietes Gebiet über
Jahre hinweg
also der der die negativen Wirkung sind
übrigens angesprochen worden die sind
vor allen Dingen Augen finde ich
geworden wenn man in die Geschichte
zurückblickt in Vietnamkrieg so groß
finde ich nicht Ströme Nationen
eingesetzt worden ist und über Jahre
Jahrzehnte Bevölkerung drunter gelitten
hat genau in dem Sinne wie es gerade
angesprochen worden ist Kinder haben das
für Spielzeug gehalten und dann fürchte
dich Verletzungen davon getragen im
Moment gehen wir davon aus dass Waffen
aus den USA geliefert werden die von den
6 % der sogenannten baumplätze das sind
diese einzelnen Sprengkörper die aus
diesem Granaten herausfallen nicht
explodieren werden
später 18 und 19 Jahre alt und 21
[Musik]
bleiben und bleiben eine Gefahr für die
ukrainische Bevölkerung die in diesem
Gebiete zurückkehren will wie viele
russische Bevölkerung im Moment in
diesem Gebieten sich befindet
wir haben eben gerade im Beitrag von
Jonas Kapp gehört was für eine
furchtbare Kriegs was Waffe das ist und
am Ende auch dass es heißt die USA sagen
sie würden moderne Varianten der Waffe
mit einer niedrigen blindgängerquote
liefern was würden Sie sagen was heißt
das genau und was bedeutet das also was
bedeutet denn eine niedrige
blindgängerquote
also es gibt eine Maßgabe des
amerikanischen Kongresses aus dem man so
ein bisschen ableiten kann das auch die
USA sich mit diesem Waffensystem etwas
unwohl trotz der Tatsache dass sie die
Konvention nicht unterzeichnet haben
dahingehend das nur Waffen geliefert
werden sollen wo sichergestellt ist das
höchstens ein Prozent der sogenannten
komplettes designersätze nicht
explodieren kann die Frage ist ja das
kann wer kann das konkret nachhalten und
noch einmal wenn man heute durch die
amerikanische Medien schaut dann solltet
auch vieles darauf hin das ist mit der
älteren Waffensystem zu tun haben wie
gesagt aus der späten 185er die eher
diese Fähigkeit nicht aufhalten und 5
für 6 % weniger nach sich ziehen würden
dementsprechend ist diese Maßnahme nicht
einzuhalten
es gibt auch Fragen jetzt bei uns ob es
schon Reaktionen gibt so fragt sich Sven
Odendahl hat sich schon die deutsche
Bundesregierung dazu verhalten er
schließt auch gleich eine Frage an aber
erstmal gehe ich auf diese ein denn wir
haben nämlich auch gleich einen O-Ton
indem wir zusammen reinhören können also
die Außenministerin Werbung hatte sich
geäußert lehnt die Lieferung von
streumutmunition an die Ukraine ab für
die Bundesregierung gelte das Osloer
Abkommen sagte sie darin ist festgelegt
das Produktion und Lagerung von
Streumunition eben verboten ist und auch
der Verteidigungsminister Pistorius hat
sich bei einer Pressekonferenz geäußert
wir hören mal zusammen rein in
Deutschland hatte die Konvention
ebenfalls unterzeichnet für uns ist das
keine Option die Länder die sich dieser
Konvention nicht angeschlossen haben und
dazu gehört neben China Russland die
Ukraine und die Vereinigten Staaten von
Amerika das habe ich nicht zu
kommentieren
was würden Sie sagen
kann Deutschland Teil einer Koalition
von Unterstützern sein eben wo diese
Munition auch geliefert wird auch wenn
Deutschland ist nicht selbst tut
also zum einen ist die Position der
Bundesregierung genauso klar wie sie
gerade zur Haustür gebracht worden es
ist immer dieser Bereich Produktion
Lagerung und Einsatz deren verboten und
die Bundesregierung war eine der
treibenden Kräfte im ostenprozess für
2010 zu dieser Konvention geführt hat
von der kann sie nicht anders handeln
kann sie heute auch nichts anderes sagen
aber die Punkte sie ansprechen ist
natürlich Liebe
ein zentrales Argument ist der beste
Unterstützung für die Ukraine der
militärischen Unterstützung ist nichts
fest gewesen dass wir uns in einer
Wertegemeinschaft befinden würden die
USA und fast Jovan fast die du reden und
fast also sein der Westen die EU die
Nato und das Argumente wird natürlich
schwerer zu machen sein wenn man jetzt
Waffen einsetzt oder die USA
zu befähigen Waffen einzusetzen die mit
deutschen politischen
Ordnungsvorstellungen auch Völkerrecht
zu bringen
und ich werde nicht verwundert wenn das
Wasser auf die Mühlen in der politischen
debattet die sich ohnehin noch nie
ausgebrochen habe aus welchen
politischen Ecke auch immer in den
letzten Wochen und Monaten die werden
sich jetzt im laufenden befinden und
sagen das ist doch nicht das wofür wird
Deutschland eingetreten hat und so
weiterhin
Sven Odenthal der User hatte auch nach
Reaktionen der NATO gefragt auch dazu
gibt es schon eine der
Nato-Generalsekretär Stoltenberg hatte
sich mit einem Statement geäußert auch
da hören wir zusammen rein
Munition wird bereits im Krieg in der
Ukraine eingesetzt und zwar von beiden
Seiten der Unterschied ist dass Russland
Streumunition einsetzt um die Ukraine
anzugreifen und die Ukraine setzt
Streumunition ein um sich gegen einen
Aggressor zu schützen
würden Sie sagen diese Unterscheidung
die kann man so machen also dass man in
dieser Frage dann wirklich diese
Unterscheidung anbringen kann
von offensiv Waffen oder offensiver
Einsatz und defensiver Einsatz das ist
kein Thema der Konvention die Konvention
ist in dieser Frage ganz klar Produktion
Lagerung und Einsatz der wird nicht
differenziert für welchen Zweck diese
Waffen eingesetzt werden sollen das soll
eben den Schutz der Zivilbevölkerung
dienen von daher auch wenn ich diese
Differenzierung politisch verstehen kann
und ich kann verstehen
keine Gültigkeit hatte aber letztlich
ist das ja keine kein Thema was die NATO
ist und treiben sollte weil die
Waffenlieferung sind zwar
naturalisiert aber letztlich ist ja das
Berlin Staaten gestellt oder einzelner
Staat bestellt welche im Umfang sie war
nie von und
da bleiben der Punkt valide die USA
mögen sich damit diskutieren oder ihre
außen und Sicherheitspolitik mag damit
ist irritiert sein aber auch von der
Tatsache dass sie nicht mehr sind
der Konvention
ist tun sie nicht illegal ist
wir haben auch die Positionen des
internationalen Komitees vom Roten Kreuz
angefragt die möchte ich hier auch kurz
anbringen und zwar hieß es dort unsere
Sorge gilt den humanitären Folgen von
Streumunition nicht nur heute sondern
auch in den kommenden Jahren vielleicht
würden sie uns da auch netterweise noch
einmal eine Einschätzung geben daran
Hassan Sade hatte eben bei uns hier in
der Sendung gesagt diese Gegend ist
sowieso schwer vermiet insofern ist die
Frage wie schwer wiegt dann jetzt auch
noch der Einsatz von stromunition das
wird sowieso Jahre dauern das Gebiet zu
befreien wie würden Sie auf diese Sorgen
vor den humanitären Folgen eben auch in
den kommenden Kriegsjahren reagieren
also ich würde ein bisschen mehr Sorgen
zu Ausdruck bringen wollen er hat ja
vorhin auf den Einsatz direkt an der
frontbezug genommen also auf die
eingegrabenen russischen Stellung da
kann man das Argument machen da muss
ohnehin grundsätzlich aufgeräumt werden
ich habe jetzt sozusagen auf die weiche
und ziehen abgehoben hin weithin im
Hinterland also im Hinterland der
russischen Frauen die sich noch auf
ukrainischen territoren befinden also
Eisenbahn Knotenpunkte Flughäfen anders
mehr und deshalb sind wir doch nicht so
ganz leicht zu sein zu sagen da muss man
aufräumen und die Idee ist ja dass diese
Gebieten wieder
ohne
eingeschalteten zur Verfügung gestellt
werden wenn du russische verdrängt oder
zurückgeschlagen sein sollte von daher
müssen wir oder muss müssen diejenigen
die mitnehmen die diesen anderen Leben
das
Gegenüber Bevölkerung
gezogen werden man kann argumentieren
das ist das bewegte ukrainischen
Regierung diese güterabhängung
vorzunehmen was ihre blindsubstitution
so zu tun als Kirmes da nicht zu
bestimmten Zielkonflikten wie es gerade
angesprochen habe ich möchte noch ein
paar Kommentare aus dem Stream mit
reinbringen Alfred Maurus schreibt bei
Youtube mich nervt dass jetzt nach dem
völkerrechtlichen Aspekt der
Streumunition gefragt wird ist der
Überfall der Russen auf die Ukraine
völkerrechtlich okay und dem schließt
sich oder in eine ähnliche Richtung geht
der Kommentar von einem anderen User
Chili Billy ich denke es geht in Ordnung
hier Russen schießen schließlich auch
mit den Dingern und dann auch noch auf
Zivilisten das Schreiben diese beiden
User also dann wir haben zum einen die
kritischen Stimmen bei uns im Stream
aber eben auch jene die da diesen
Vergleich anstellen zum Schluss finde
ich die Frage aber noch interessant denn
wir haben ja auch gehört und gelernt in
diesem Stream es gibt sehr sehr viele
Länder die international eben den
Einsatz von stromunition echten Glauben
sie das könnte aber auch etwas mit dem
Bild der Ukraine machen diese Frage
hatte ich auch schon unserem Reporter
gestellt aber eben vielleicht auch etwas
in Bezug auf nächste Waffenlieferung für
die Ukraine glauben Sie das jetzt
vielleicht auch beim NATO Gipfel einfach
da noch eine härtere Reaktion von den
Ländern kommen könnte die eben Streu
Munition echten
kurz und langfristigen Folgen
unterscheiden wollen kurzfristige
NATO-Gipfel am Dienstag Mittwoch dass
die Agenda gesetzt da wird es um andere
Fragen gehen es wird um
verteidigungsförderung gegen Bewusstsein
gehen Direktversicherung für die Staaten
aus der Europas Runde fahren in der
abschreitungen und vor allem in die
Zukunft der Anbindung der Ukraine an die
NATO die Frage an der Mitgliedschaft ist
eine Woche im Monat verdient gewesen ich
sehe nicht dass diese Frage von
Kommunikationen auf der generieren
wollen aber letztlich kann es natürlich
die politische Lage in der Bestimmung in
dem Sinne wie sie immer angesprochen
habe der russische Präsident jetzt auf
den langen Krieg ersetzt darauf dass die
Unterstützung westlichen
Industrienationen für die Waffen nicht
finden
schwindet das ist so eine
regierungscheune USA kommt gleich dann
in anderen Stadt europasen und in diesem
Kontext ist natürlich ein ich ganz
ungewichtiges arme hinten dass
sicherlich in der politischen
gebracht werden sozusagen wollen wir
diese Ukraine die gerichtete Munition
oder einsetzt
mehr einsetzen wird
militärisch und politische unterstützen
das kann man so sehen und ich kann nicht
vorstellen
nur das ist sozusagen ein dünner Grad in
die Ukraine zu gehen hat
eine Analyse von Markus Keim von der
Stiftung Wissenschaft im Politik vielen
Dank
sehr gerne
und vielen Dank auch an euch wir haben
es angesprochen es wird ein NATO-Gipfel
geben der wird natürlich auch bei uns
hier jederzeit bei ZDF heute berichtet
und ihr seid da immer informiert jetzt
für heute erstmal vielen Dank euch ein
schönes Wochenende und tschüss